hi guys having such pretty much the
entirety of the internet I've compiled a
list on the five best theories on how
all my eventually dies I've read a lot
of theories to get to this point and I
gotta say these one stood out to me the
most by far especially the number one
this video contains no spoilers for the
anime it's simply just hypothetical
theories that could end up happening so
anime only viewers you are safe but
quickly before you begin if you love my
ear academia please subscribe to this
channel I have a ton of other my hero
academia lists also something I've been
doing recently anyone who shares this
video on Twitter or social media your
user name is automatically included in
the end credits of my next video so yeah
please share this video because the
number one theory that I picked is so
good I'm actually gonna do things
differently this week and start from
first place and work our way down so the
number one theory on this this is
without a doubt the most messed up but
it actually stays within the bounds of
what we could realistically expect to
happen I'm not joking when I initially
read this theory I got goose bumps
coming from a reddit commenter whose
name is way too difficult to pronounce
and number one theory as to how all my
eventually dies is that he's turned into
a no move and deku embargo are going to
be the ones to kill him for the greater
good
this honestly game he did shows because
it's a possibility so dark all might
being turned into basically an ugly
version of frankenstein or even uglier
version serving the league of villains
it would probably be the worst way for
the symbol of peace to go out and I
don't even need to explain how much deck
who loves this guy I mean deck whose
love for all my probably runs deeper
than it does for his own father whoever
the hell that is and as if that wasn't
enough in one of my favorite episodes
which is episode 12 of season 2 we saw a
flashback as to how back ago literally
modeled his belief system his way of
viewing life off of all my all my is
both an idol and a mentor to both these
boys so the idea that they would have to
kill him and not only just kill him but
kill him in no move form is actually
sickening I personally don't like the
idea of war might being you know
captured tortured turned into a creature
and then forced to you know destroy or
hurt civilians that's something you
would never obviously do normally it
would definitely leave a very bitter
taste in the mouth but I believe is
definitely still plausible now that he's
a civilian he can't defend himself from
these type of threats this theory
absolutely deserved the number one spot
so credit to the user who came up with
this but please horikoshi do not
this to us do not do this at second
place on the list we have the theory
that I definitely saw repeated them most
often I saw multiple variations of it so
I can't really attribute it to one user
but at number two we have sugar our key
being the one to kill all might in my
personal view I truly believe that with
everything we've seen this is the most
plausible scenario however there are
multiple ways that it can actually go
down one example that caught my
attention was a theory that all might
reveals to Shigure aki the sugar Aki's
grandmother is the one who gave all my
his power this in turn could lead to
sugar aki basically freaking out and
killing all might by accident this
theory is especially plausible given
that the revelation would show shigaraki
that he's basically been a pawn in all
four one's grand plan over time I do
believe that all for one does genuinely
care about tom russia kuraki however
from sugar hockey's perspective it would
make things painfully obvious but all
for one you know finding him and
nurturing him to be a successor it
wasn't simply a coincidence but rather a
calculated decision to mess with all my
and anyway in sugar hockey's confusion
it is highly probable to me that he
would touch on my by accident or indeed
on purpose to make him stop talking
perhaps but you know we'll just see what
happens hopefully he doesn't die until
dec who graduates at least the next
theory was so powerful that i don't
actually think putting it into my own
words would do it justice so i'm just
going to read it out and then i'm gonna
give my take after
so the initial theory comes from a
reddit user whose name is crowe whoa
Paulus I think I said that right and the
post itself is two years old
now the bit of the post that interests
me was this the climax will mirror how
the story began all might will come
across an incident where no one is
taking action and someone's life is at
risk
he will just hurt himself over and over
again there's nothing I can do
I'm not a hero anymore but then he will
see the look on the person's face his
body will move without him realizing and
he'll tried to save the person because
it looked like they were asking for help
it would be the perfect kind of parallel
how the heroic spirit that exists in
both deku and all my spurred them to
action before and after they had their
quirk we do know that all might has been
incredibly unwell ever since his first
fight with all-4-one you know he's been
coughing up blood since basically the
first episode so if he were to run into
action like this he'd probably end up in
the hospital and eventually pass away
with loved ones by his side
I imagine Deku has to be there probably
followed by recovery girl Aizawa
principal Nez
maybe a few other characters like Mario
around him I imagine he not only tells
deku how proud he is of him
but that he's sorry he won't be able to
see him become the hero he's meant to be
something along those lines and then
getting to the main thing what I would
love to see him do is say to Deku never
stop smiling at this point that he's
probably got a massive frown on his face
and just before my eyes he looks like
him in the eyes
and gives him the classic all my massive
grin before dying right there
so at fourth place on the list is the
theory that all might is killed by all
for one I actually think this theory is
quite unlikely to ever happen if you
recall the battle in Kamino also one
pretty much said you know this is what
I've groomed sugar Aki to do he has to
be the one to do it but if you want to
fight me then I'll do it the thing that
made the battling Caminos so great apart
from obviously the awesome dialogue
we're all for all for one used all
meit's catchphrase
the best thing about the battle apart
from all that was that all for one and
all might were almost evenly matched
that's what made it so interesting you
didn't know what was gonna happen
and in fact many people at the time
thought that all might was going to die
there and then so to have the symbol of
peace be simply killed in his weakened
state for only way I see this being
interesting is if all might is captured
right all one is out of jail and tell
shigaraki to kill all my but at justice
shigaraki is about to kill all my all
might tells him the truth about his
grandma and then she gurashi hesitates
or maybe refuses to kill all my because
he needs time to you know process the
information and in a fit of rage all for
one uses his air cannon to send all my
flying into a wall this would be even
better if just as Almighty is about to
smash into the wall the heroes break in
to save all mine just as he's flying
through the air and then Dec we may be
uses for cowling to reach all my but
doesn't make it in time that would be
quite reminiscent of the scene in the
amazing spider-man 2 where spider-man
just fails to save Gwen Stacy those
deaths are always the most heartbreaking
for heroes when they were like so close
to saving someone and couldn't do it I
think something like that would make it
very interesting otherwise it's kind of
boring because it's thought it would be
the third fight between all for one and
all my and this time is kind of an
unfair fight and finally in fifth place
we have the death that all might
deserves and that prediction is this
dying of old age surrounded by loved
ones in a villain free society being
realistic the mentor to the main
character almost never goes out
peacefully even all might himself had to
see his mentor being killed when he was
only 18 but given that everything almost
done for society this would definitely
be the most fitting end I'm gonna go
into minor minor - full of territory
here so if you're anime only please
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next week for those of you that
don't mind I personally think that with
Aerys rewind quark she could rewind all
my body back to the time before his
first fight with all-4-one this would
erase the injury to his stomach and
perhaps enable him to live the rest of
his life in a normal manner I doubt this
rewind would give him back the power of
one for all obviously you can't take it
from Deku and I doubt there could be two
one for all existing simultaneously that
would be really really cool though
that'll be awesome but I don't think
that will happen either way the
introduction of area allows for the
possibility of all Mike actually
of old age rather than everything else
we talked about I think in all mites
small might form he is too vulnerable
for the possibility of dying of old age
and there you have it that was the list
of the top five theories of how all
might eventually does I encourage you to
let me know if you have any alternative
theories that you think maybe deserves a
place on this list and please like it if
you had a good time with this video and
also check out my last few videos
massive shout out to everyone on this
screen right now everyone that you're
currently seeing on screen either
tweeted or retweeted my last video I
can't let you know how much I appreciate
that you know it spreads the word thank
you to everyone who shared my last video
I really appreciate it don't forget to
subscribe and I'll catch you later
you